[Music]
well it's happened we're having battle
royale moments in a Call of Duty game
and that's kind of awesome if you've
been addicted to fortnight or pub G this
is probably your best chance to try a
new take on the formula with that said
there's a few things you'll experience
in blackout number one vertical space
not only is the blackout beta map huge
but it has a lot of space to explore
above and below ground landing zones
such as construction bring multiple
levels of dense fighting into one place
this is also a great area to use barbed
wire if you can find some the cargo
docks and factory zones both have loot
and routes underwater you can even find
valuable crates underneath the surface
especially on docks to complement the
vertical space ruins grappling hook can
be found and used to get to unexpected
places
number two secrets so far most of the
secrets in blackout revolve around
zombies finding and killing the undead
leads to high-level gear such as the ray
gun reliable zombie fights can be found
by landing at asylum but random beams of
light also drop around the map and
indicate the location of high-level loot
also guarded by the undead there are
other secret areas if you know where to
look
landing on the outskirts of Newtown
island reveals entrances to a bunker
complex that would make fallout proud
number 3 by air land and sea those who
play pub G will be familiar with
hovering on the outskirts of a circle
with a boat but blackout also lets you
do this with helicopters choppers don't
have guns for their blast to fly and
grated zipping between locations they're
good at burning time while the field
whittles itself down and if you have a
talented squad willing to shoot off the
sides you can try going hunting with one
good luck be aware that helicopters make
a lot of noise take damage from primary
weapons and can be locked onto you by
ground-based rocket launchers so make
sure to fly fast and use terrain for
cover
number four abilities like weapons and
attachments abilities can be looted
around the map multiple ones can be used
at the same time potentially making you
superhuman while they last
some of the more useful ones to look out
for early on let you see loot and
vehicles through walls because you'll
find a steady stream of them it's to
your advantage to constantly pick them
up and activate them but if you feel
safe enough hover over their description
to see what they do when you get more
experienced you may want to save some
boosts for the final circle number five
inventory that day has finally come when
you have to manage the inventory of a
Call of Duty game fortunately most of
the items you run across have the option
to equip them from the ground I can save
a lot of time there's some important
things to know such as using the ammo
storage area on the upper left of your
screen to drop ammo that you don't need
for your squad as of right now make sure
to pull attachments off of a weapon
before swapping to a better gun on the
ground in order to use those attachments
on your new weapon we would love a swap
weapon and attachments button in a
future beta also keep in mind that
looting dead players is extremely slow
as you deep had your way through their
inventory so if you think there were
enemies nearby don't bother
number 6 special events battle royale
involves a lot of hiking which is
designed to ratchet up attention but for
some it's just a lot of hiking games
like fortnight have done a fantastic job
at giving players tons of activities
challenges and ongoing story elements
while they make their way to the final
circle blackout so far has announced
there will be special modes over the
beta the first of which was fast
collapse and the second close quarters
we're hoping to see a lot of creativity
with special modes because called new
he's known for it I'm looking at you gun
game prop hunt sticks and stones so
here's the hoping for a great variety or
maybe even big team battles alright we'd
like to hear your tips and tricks based
on the first blackout beta what would
you change from what you've played so
far the next round of testing comes to
Xbox one and PC and we look forward to
seeing you there
thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]